[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui s'est passé dans ma tête
durant ton arrivée
[Rires]
et après quand je t'ai vu là je dis oh
non ça va je te jure
et puis quand tu es là je me dis non il
est beau gosse c'est sympa bonne année
chéri
en tout cas
comme d'habitude comment ça va fais ton
boulot
mais qui accueille un chroniqueur comme
ça
non mais tu as une symétrie dans le
village que je le vois pas ailleurs je
te jure que c'est vrai non mais ça passe
on pourrait prendre ton visage pour un
contrôle de géométrie c'est un truc de
fou donc là c'est le look qui va pas
alors oui c'est très beau je suis désolé
tu vois mais ouais mais là
un coup là je te parle je te parle en
deux minutes vas-y commence
pas du moral des autres on travaille
de Cyril dans un instant parce que là
vous le voyez en train de boire il fait
le malin mais on l'a piégé cette semaine
et pas que pendant les pubs vous allez
voir ce qu'il va manger le patron là
dans un instant on va voir si j'ai une
tête géométrique après hein vous allez
vous calmer monsieur
toujours vivant Cyril pour cette
nouvelle année j'ai décidé d'être encore
plus Tarma et j'ai décidé de vous suivre
toute la semaine donc on a décidé de
créer un truc très simple ça s'appelle
la semaine de Cyril Hanouna et la
semaine ça commence par quel jour ça
commence par le non le lundi
donc début de semaine compliqué pour
Cyril puisque parler des tuiles à
bourdes
donc on a commencé la semaine Cyril avec
un petit problème de santé vous avez eu
mal quelque part regarde
j'ai une douleur en dessous des couilles
est-ce que ça va mieux
toi tu vas avoir une douleur à la gueule
[Rires]
pour détendre le public
d'accord ok je te le dis bah vous avez
pas de métier ça va prendre les gros
animateurs
j'ai mal aux couilles
une personne est venue sur le plateau
Cyril lundi qui vous a remonté le moral
d'une personne que vous adorez c'est
votre chouchou et j'ai l'impression que
les petites histoires d'amour qui naît
j'adore regarde la spécialiste royauté
et permanente qui sera avec nous dans un
instant Bertrand Descartes
[Musique]
et nous je ne savent comme film à toi
je l'adore
je l'adore sa veste
il y a eu d'autres invités qui sont
venus dans les missions et ils étaient
pas très polis non et donc j'ai un
conseil pour tous les prochains invités
qui vont venir sur ce plateau n'oubliez
pas les formules de politesse avec Cyril
parce que sinon vous pouvez en prendre
plein la gueule
dans un instant merci
[Musique]
tu vas voir merci ça marche
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
[Rires]
ça s'est bien passé après avec les
écolos on passe à mardi je suis à la
semaine de vendredi
peut-être peut-être mais on commence
bien l'année on commence près de la
sortie de la de l'accueil allez vas-y on
passe à mardi qui dit nouvelle nouveau
joueur dit nouvelle outfit nouvel outfit
nouvelle tenue de Cyril parce que vous
savez que Cyril ose cette année en 2023
il y en a un qui a été comment dire
surpris par votre nouvelle tenue un
qu'on est du coup pas prête de revoir
dans l'émission alors si il sort des
vannes de vieux de ouf je sais c'est
insupportable c'est Jean-Michel
[Applaudissements]
le vendredi on va faire une boule
[Musique]
c'est comme quand tu sors avec Kat ta
mère qui croise et qui fait oh là
qu'est-ce que c'est que tu sais quand tu
mets des jeans avec un peu de peinture
écoute de la musique de sauvages
mardi toujours ou pas
est-ce que on va éviter cette tenue
cette tenue qu'on va revoir dans un
instant c'était pas si dégueulasse mais
je pense savoir pourquoi vous avez mis
cette tenue parce que faut savoir que
Cyril c'est le nouvel agent de sécurité
de l'émission fini Mokhtar tout ça cyril
a pris la relève s'il y a un problème de
sécu sur le plateau ou en dehors cyril
est là pour régler le problème regardez
les chéris les chéris faites attention
juste les séries quand vous sortez du
studio faites gaffe dans la soirée du
studio vous passez par là il y a des
bouffeurs de cul
c'est pour des temps de publications
radio
là parce que les audiences radio c'est
n'importe quoi il y a que des erreurs
que des trucs c'est n'importe quoi parce
que je connais les oignons donc voilà
donc si ça ça pour moi c'est un torchon
voilà je vous dis voilà
c'est moi qui devait le faire en plus
donc
non
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est de
la merde
apparemment il est plus occupé à
chercher des vestes Villaines il va
prendre dans la tronche maintenant
capable qui pourrait prendre ce poste
qui va prendre le vote dans un instant
Mathieu ça c'est vrai mais on est sur la
semaine de Cyril la semaine de Cyril on
passe à mercredi mais bien sûr parce que
attendez moi j'ai que accumulé plein de
trucs donc mercredi Cyril cette année
vous avez décidé d'aimer tous vos
chroniqueurs de la même manière sauf un
regard qui c'est
bon c'est bon tu es bon et tu es beau
ouais si je veux dire parfois les mecs
sont juste bon tu vois comme Gilles toi
tu es bon quand même
[Applaudissements]
tu es très beau oui très beau bon
toujours dit que c'était le meilleur
chroniqueur c'est toujours dit Géraldine
parce que c'est des beautés différentes
chacun à avoir mis à sa porte
et tu sais que la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
de chez moi je t'ai regardé et j'ai eu
un flash je me suis dit Gilles devrait
se laisser pousser la barbe en mode
hipster raccourcir sur les côtés et
comme ça un peu du volume
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut savoir quitter la table quand le
meilleur exemple
oui bon alors on continue avec avec
Cyril Hanouna qui visiblement
des SMS
[Applaudissements]
on prend un savon parce qu'on a les
portables
il y a 2 minutes on n'avait pas le droit
Guillaume Genton dans la ligne
c'est mon frère
[Rires]
allez continue c'est vachement des
audience radio
continue avec Cyril donc qui visiblement
en plus d'être un menteur
de ce que j'ai lu le message
vous Siri
moi je suis plutôt une occasion plutôt
neuf regardez Cyril le marché de
l'occasion c'est pas son délire quand tu
parles regardez non mais arrête moi
83000 bornes
non mais elle est belle tu me l'as il va
acheter une voiture 83000 bornes
frère c'est comme si tu voulais qu'elle
Daniel Moreau
non mais frère
[Musique]
dès demain
tout le monde vous en particulier allez
c'est les meilleurs vous dire la vérité
sur un piège qui a duré toute la semaine
figurez-vous qu'on a piégé Cyril et
franchement moi j'étais pas pour elle à
la base je vous le dis je préfère me
détruire d'arrêter de ce piège mais vous
avez été pranké avec des chocolats
piégés des chocolats au lait sur son lit
de Tabasco les téléspectateurs en plus
ça hier en direct et en fait on a testé
ce piège tout au long de la semaine je
vous propose de regarder l'extrait et on
en parle juste après tu vas tester sur
audio
alors on a testé lundi vous mettre une
boîte de chocolat piégé mais vous les
avez pas mangé
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on
a réessayé mardi mon ami Alexandre a
remis cette boîte de chocolat que j'ai
vous ne les avez pas mangé mais de sois
loué hier vous les avez mangé
qu'est-ce que vous dites
oui vous les avez mangé mais ils étaient
piégés
[Musique]
une petite surprise dedans
c'est quoi la surprise
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous défoncer
derrière ce piège vous avez un peu
d'oseille sur vous allez dépêche-toi
alors je vous propose de regarder en
images mais c'est une personne que vous
appréciez jusqu'ici ça risque de changer
c'est toi moi regarde carrément
[Musique]
c'est terrible régale-toi mon petit
bonhomme
[Applaudissements]
non non le pire c'est pas ça c'est vous
avez entendu l'extrait d'avant elle
voulait insister alors que c'est elle
qui l'avait fait je le fais au nom de
mes petits camarades
et je dirais à la ministre des PME dans
un instant moi 50 % pour vol
le cagnotte
lundi on recevait Véronique jeunesse
outre le très bel accueil
est-ce que tu es quand même arrivé à 17h
il est 19h30
[Musique]
je me suis cassé le nez à l'antenne sur
M6 parce que je voulais faire en fait je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'était ce
personnage je voulais faire depuis très
longtemps et j'en parlais à la direction
de M6 Thomas Valentin patron le
directeur des programmes tout ça parce
que je me suis étais persuadé que
j'avais une idée faut que j'arrêtais pas
de leur dire je vais faire bientôt un
maître nageur peintre il me dit mais
c'est quoi c'est un maître nageur en
fait qui saute contre les murs en
nageant on fait des peintures et genre
le téléspectateur de trouver ce que je
pense
[Musique]
il était pas comme un ouf tu vois pas et
un jour
les mecs demain matin je le fais sur je
fais le maître nageur
c'est sur vous et c'est normal comme ils
l'ont dit à tout le monde et tout le
monde ait peur que je fasse ça parce que
j'allais mettre de la peinture partout
parce que je me je me renversais des
sauts de peinture dessus je sauté contre
le mur et ils ont eu la bonne idée pour
ne pas que je saccage M6 demain
le nez sur le sol comme ça en fait je
tombe comme ça TOI
et là je me rappelle j'ai cette phrase
magnifique c'est on arrête tout là
donc là je pars chez les pompiers
directs
donc voilà et là et je me rappelle il y
a le directeur général M6 et regarder
parce qu'il y avait ma gloire qui était
avec moi qui a fait tous les morning et
qui les a chronique
très longtemps l'acronyme
c'est magma qui m'avait remplacé et donc
il m'appelle et là je lui dis bah non
bah j'ai fait le ballon je suis dans le
camion des pompiers là je commence à
dans le camion des pompiers bah ouais
parce que j'ai fait le maître nageur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai 26 maintenant
en parlant de leur mot en 2023
figurez-vous qu'il n'a pas changé il est
toujours aussi gratteur en plus de venir
gratter son cachet qu'il ne mérite pas
figurez-vous le mec il gratte des dîners
avec les invités et ça série va falloir
saisir qu'on regarde les invités
[Applaudissements]
en plus d'être un gratteur figurez-vous
qui va rentrer dans les annales de la
mauvaise foi pour une fois Cyril il ne
s'agit pas de vous qui êtes mauvaise foi
mais de Mathieu tu vas prendre un coup
dans ta gueule il y a quelques jours
Marco Molly regarde bien la réaction de
Mathieu Delormeau j'en dis pas plus
notre ami Marco Molly
comment ça va bien ou quoi
[Musique]
je pense qu'il doit nous regarder et je
pense qu'il va revenir la semaine
prochaine je pense ça va être compliqué
donc voilà non
et vous savez qu'entre temps j'ai dîné
avec Marco Molly
et on a organisé le dîner chez maman